so we joke about robots taking over but
they're really helpful
for police so what's the big deal well
let's take a look
and there is the robot that looks like
your classic boston
dynamics robot i've never seen nothing
like this before in my life
yeah me neither i've never seen that
either oh that's
more better than a dog somehow it
doesn't look as cute when it's dressed
up as a police officer in police livery
and this raises all kinds of fourth
amendment issues
according to the supreme court in terry
vs ohio the police are allowed to detain
and search people if there is a
reasonable suspicion but what does that
mean in the context of robots
who might have sensors that are far more
sensitive than
humans they might be just patrolling
around
does that give them the ability to stop
people just using a remote controlled
robot
does it infringe on constitutional
liberties this is not an issue that's
going to go away police departments are
probably going to use more and more
robots
but we'll see what the courts say